our schedule calls for for a few
introductory remarks I'm going to make
those and then I'm going to pass the mic
to to my colleague here da gray and what
I will do is just give you a bit of a
sense of of the nature of our course and
what we have covered so far and say a
few words about our own engagement with
the question of religion and violence in
the context of globalization processes I
know that you've had also a unit on
fundamentalism and extremism and we'd be
very interested in hearing content of
your discussions on those on those
issues can you hear me well up down yes
excellent I think we are moving so so
first brief a brief summary our own
course here on faith and globalization
has roughly is roughly divided in two
parts first part is kind of general
considerations in which we have examined
significance of globalization in
globalization processes and also its
impact on the world of faiths and then
we looked at the couplet faith in
globalization from other side
significance of faiths today and also
their possible impact upon globalization
processes and so so so after these
general study of the relationship
between the two we went into we started
going into specific areas such as issues
that concern business human rights
gender issues and so forth and we are
right now in the section dealing with
faith and reconciliation faith and
violence so roughly that's where we are
in our in our course and during this
course we have been pursuing kind of two
fundamental issues one of these
fundamental issues were kind of the
accounts the sense of the self of social
relations and the good that are
encoded in the great faith traditions
and also that shape globalization
processes we've also talked about roles
of faith in generating violence in the
world today as well as being potential
sources for more harmonious
relationships and right now we are on
generation vial of violence part of our
of our series of reflections and this
idea of association between faith and
violence of course is significant in the
context of globalization because
globalization creates an interconnected
and interdependent world where as
religions often serve to ground to
legitimize strengthened particular
identities and these two things often
are in conflict with with one another
and today conflicts are justified more
by in religious terms and legitimize
more in religious terms than in terms of
ideology and this is a significant
problem in an interdependent world so
but what is precisely the link I think
we have to ask between religion and
contemporary violence and what we've
done in the course of our reflections in
this seminar is to ask the question
whether religion is the main factor
proxy for something else those will be
two opposing positions or one of the
factors and the phrase that I have used
is in this regard is that all mono
causal explanations are suspects so
religion is one possible reasons and
causes of violence but certainly not the
only one and maybe also not the most
important one and certainly not the most
important one in all of the particular
instances and now we are returning to
this question you know from a slightly
different angle and asking the question
questions our faiths by nature violent
as suggests and if not under what
conditions do they turn and
come of Ireland so the character of
fades themselves and also conditions
under which fades become violent so let
me address very briefly these questions
so RF fades by nature valve Ireland in
popular presentations today such as
Christopher Hitchens a book God is not
great or similar books often religion is
portrayed as inherently violent he has a
little phrase which says simply religion
kills and in his account religion kills
because religion is a form of mental
delusion is a form of bad conscience
form of untruth and not just that it is
form of mental delusion but also a great
moral evil now we haven't read Hitchens
text or any of such texts I consider
them kind of fundamentalist a these
forms of fundamentalist atheism rather
flat but nonetheless very influential
today what we've instead done and we've
shared these readings with you is we've
read Jergens Meyers book or sections of
that book who develops a bit more
sophisticated thesis and suggests that
there is kind of ambivalence of religion
a religion containing deep within its
own character seeds of violence as well
as at the same time seeds of peace and
he suggests that religious imagination
always has had propensity to absolute
eyes and to project images of cosmic war
that's not part of the reading in part
of the reading that we had a sign but
toward the end of the book he offers
this kind of a summary at the same time
he suggests also every religious
tradition has projected images of
tranquility and of peace and so his
suggestion is that religion is important
because it gives spirit to public life
and provides a kind of a beacon of moral
order yet at the same time it needs to
be tempered and needs to be tempered by
rationality and fair play that for him
derives primarily
from enlightenment convictions so in
Jergens meyer you have this ambivalence
of religion we read also Girard and for
jerod Renner are the famous theorists of
religion religions are always responds
to already present violence and the
reason for that violence is what he
calls mimetic desire and mimetic rivalry
that mimetic rivalry is the foundational
character of human behavior and
religions are designed in many ways to
mitigate against violence that is
existent in societies and they do so in
different ways through ritual which
mimics scapegoating and resolve mimetic
crisis as he said and some religions are
notably he suggests Judaism and
Christianity exposed the scapegoating
mechanism and in such way function to
reduce the violence we have also
mentioned briefly now are not in our
readings but in our discussions the
thesis of David Martin who was a
professor of sociology at the London
School of Economics who suggests that
there are that each of the religious
tradition has a repertoire of of ideas
and depending on how these reppert or
which portions of the repertoire are
played religions can be either violent
or contribute to to peace and that then
ask bleats look if that's the case that
leads to the question and what
conditions do fates become violent now I
think that we have to distinguish and it
may be interesting for us to discuss we
have to distinguish between external and
internal conditions and which religions
become violent all right we haven't done
much in our readings about those
external conditions under which
religions become violent and I would
want to suggest that those external
conditions are often associated the
religions become violent when
when they are associated when specific
religions are associated with political
power and second when they are
associated with holy space so I think
Anakin regulating the space and
political power in the function of
religions in these kinds of settings
they often then become and contribute to
generating become violent and contribute
to generating violence so association of
religion with political power power
which needs to be legitimized and power
which needs to be defended that is say
as distinct from a secular reading of
power understanding of power and
religion more is a privatized private
private affair or as distinct from a
political power which is being
disassociated from any particular
religion but all forms of religiosity
present in the political space can shape
that exercise of that power or when you
think about holy space where identity of
religion and of people embracing
religion is tightly connected with
particular geographic locales or
particular architecture to use a very
neutral the term holy object and holy
holy sites and that's is distinct from
religion being highly portable all right
some forms of Buddhism are such some
forms of Christianity pentecostalism are
such or religions as having actually
nothing like holy sites early
Christianity Christians met in house
churches anyhow could do and so there
was no tying of religion to a particular
holy space so that's a kind of external
condition put the political association
with political power association with
holy space for readings today we have
primarily concentrated on internal
conditions of the religion religion
itself and those internal conditions
especially in the readings that we that
we've that we've had they concerned the
absolute truth claims of of religion and
these absolute truth claims the question
is that the
the issue is whether the fact that or at
least the claim that religions make
absolute truth claims whether that as
such is all red ly violence generating
so that would be the Klaine about the
nature of religious language or possible
form that religious language takes and I
think that may be a significant issue
for us to to discuss we have also spent
quite a bit of time in in our class
talking about religious exclusivism and
whether the fact that many religions are
exclusivist by this I suppose we mean
that many of religions claim that they
are if not the only then at least the
most truthful and best ways of getting
in contact with the divine whether that
claim itself is already such that
generates generates violence I think it
may be good for us to take our pick up
these two I think there are related
question questions of religious in
exclusivism and question of the
character of religious truth claims and
then see to what extent they themselves
are generated generative of violence now
one can just just as a suggestion one
may distinguish between the way in which
religious truths are held right the
certain level of certainty or to put it
paradoxically almost level absoluteness
with which they are held right and the
content of what these claims are the
content of this of these claims and
these are two distinct issues right is
it the case that the way in which
religious claims are held the the amount
of certitude that is gender violence
generating or is it the actual content
of those claims or
might it be some combination of both
that contributes to to violence in the
course of our discussions early on we
have a specially professor Blair has
referred to what can be described as a
distinction between thick religiosity
and thin religiosity religiosity which
has depth and religiosity which is a
kind of like sacred canopy over social
processes that go on in any case and
thick religiosity would be religiosity
which has robust moral vision embedded
in it again moral vision about the self
about social relations about the good
and it's part of an overarching
interpretation of life that has a VAD
and not just a sense of connection with
transcendence and that engages over
periods of time in traditions of
argument about these issues right so
it's a it's a thick in the sense that it
has depth rather than thick in the sense
that it's very zealous you can have a
very thick religiosity in on zealous
religiosity you can have very thin
religiosity which can be very zealous
right thin religiosity on the other hand
discards moral vision and discards the
tradition long tradition of more moral
reasoning with in religions and but
retains this sense of ultimately Ultima
see sense of sacredness and often then
shrouds what our worldly so to speak
causes in the aura of the sacred and the
thesis is has been propounded that
religion tends to be more violent when
it's thin religiosity in the sense that
was defined here rather than when it's
this thick religiosity that is when
religions serve simply to legitimize and
to energize causes ideas
programs that derive its content from
other sources that religion itself
rather than religions that when
religions define the moral universe in
which people ought to ought to behave
now that's also very controversial
thesis if I have managed to explain it
adequately to you and it is a matter it
would be a matter of maybe interesting
discussion that we might have I think
I'm going to stop right here and pass on
to my colleague professor ray